all right we are on location at the
blaze studios here in Dallas Texas
and I'm sitting across from mr. blaze
Glenn Beck all right sir how's it going
my man good to see you thank you for
letting us do an on-location shoot I
feel not a problem I know you're here
for about 10 minutes and then you're I
think you're gonna probably be on the
moon and then a stop at the Mars and you
know a little bit about traveling a lot
I do yeah so I'm in-between a thousand
things here great yeah it's it's pretty
cool I want to spend a lot of time
talking about this book here addicted to
outrage but let's just do everything so
right now we're about two and a half
weeks away from this midterm election I
suspect something completely bananas
over the next two and a half weeks I
mean you can already just see between
between the cabin ah stuff that we've
been dealing with the general outrage
and all the things you're writing about
here so here we just said this to a
group friends the other day I think at
this point a spaceship could appear okay
and hover over New York City and to be
like oh I mean I don't know what would
surprise me now it what we be arguing
about the gender pronouns the aliens you
know no I know it's it's absolutely
insane how everything is everything is
upside-down everything is upside down do
you think do you think we're in a unique
time because that's one of the questions
when I'm out there with Peterson people
say okay it's you know everyone says
we've never been more partisan and we're
angrier than ever and all of these
things but just something about this
seem unique yeah I'm a I'm a glutton for
history yes and it we have been in
perilous times before I don't think
we've hit the civil war confrontations
yet but we are approaching it do you
think we really are cuz I do because I'm
actually worried about the amount of
people I you see this on Twitter all the
time people saying oh civil war is
coming you know like yeah like murmur
about what would be the most horrific
possible outcome of all of this so
remind me to talk about the window
because I think we have a window right
but we have been we've been worse
I mean if you look at Jefferson and
Adams you know Adams Adams was called a
hermaphrodite by Jefferson Jefferson
Jefferson his campaign called him a
hermaphrodite
Adams said back that if you elect Thomas
Jefferson there will be blood in the
streets and the heads of our children
and your daughters will be on pikes into
every town so we've had rhetoric like
this before
ironically I'd be thrilled to vote for
either one of I'll take either I don't
care heads on pikes but it all does go
to just in the last couple weeks you
know there was this Hillary Clinton lyin
on CNN talking to Christian Amanpour
about how we can't be civil because
these these people meaning the
Conservatives or Republicans are so
against our values I mean this is
dangerous stuff here's the difference we
have been in these places before but we
knew our founding documents we knew who
we served or who our God was and I don't
know who our God is now I mean is it
money is it Fame is it anger I don't
know what our God is now we knew wait
let me pause you there for a sec so when
you when you say that about what the
founders believed now they were also
saying separation of church and state
the whole time so if you were just
laying out what they believed
when you say who our God was so George
Washington they did believe in the
division of church and state clearly I
do too yeah that just means if you're an
atheist yes we're friends we're cool
let's get along but if you're a god
person you do your god thing you do your
atheist thing right do we have what Adam
Smith called moral sentiment in common
yes capitalism has lost the first volume
of Adam Smith the second volume is
Wealth of Nations the first volume is
Moral Sentiments and that's a
look this is an invisible hand and the
market is powerful and it will create
whatever you want be careful what you
ask for make sure you are always
tempering the moral sentiment make sure
that you're a good decent fair-minded
people we've lost that we're losing it I
should say and I'm concerned and I talk
about this a bit in the book I've seen
this coming for almost two decades and I
have been warning against it and for the
very first time I'm at the place where
I'm on the air now saying this is the
time this is the time that I said would
come yeah and now is the time for you to
remember who you are and our outrage is
taking us away from it so as I've looked
at this for so long I have I have
studied revolutions I have I've studied
giant movements of chaos I I can tell
you about you know the I think it was
the red month in the 1930s like I can
show you what's happened but there were
three people in four people in grand
movements that have gotten it right
there was Abraham Lincoln mm-hmm
there was Martin Luther King there was
Gandhi then there's Bonhoeffer
Bonhoeffer do you know who Dietrich
Bonhoeffer was I don't think so hey
Bonhoeffer lost okay Bonhoeffer was a a
pastor I think Lutheran in Germany he
was on the air when the Fuehrer declared
he was Fuhrer he was taken his broadcast
was cut in short because he was doing a
broadcast called the Fuhrer a principle
this is wrong don't go this way he on
Kristallnacht
the very next morning he was shopping in
those stores those Jewish stores
pacifist he tried to turn the Germans
back and say stop it
stop stop you're going the wrong way he
couldn't do it he eventually escaped
from Germany was in New York not here
very long as he felt guilty how can I
leave my country when it's in this much
trouble he went back he realized there's
no there no he's a stopped this guy
maybe violence is the answer he was
involved in one of the attempts to kill
Hitler he went to a concentration camp
he died he was executed like five days
before Hitler died here's the thing if
you read his writings he's gone - he's
Jesus he's Martin Luther King he's he's
got it and now Terry read him and read
him and read him how why did he fail
silence in the face of evil is evil
itself not to stand is to stand he's got
it love one another don't stop playing
the organ so you can hear that the train
going to Auschwitz okay he failed
because Germans had already gone over
the cliff they had because of World War
one
then the Treaty of Versailles then the
1920s they had already lost their
judeo-christian principles they had lost
their Center remember if it wasn't for
England Gandhi would have failed people
think of Gandhi is starving himself to
get the British to comply no he starved
himself to say to his own people do not
rise up in anger they were this close to
losing and he knew it he was appealing
to the sense of decency and fairness of
the British culture so he knew the
people because of their judeo-christian
worldview would see this oppression and
go that's wrong if we have a window and
it's closing yeah if we give in to our
anger our outrage and we say you know
what I can't take it anymore we will
lose and that window of the
judeo-christian values will close and
then we're done yeah it's so interesting
because one of the themes that keep
coming up as I'm on this tour is people
keep asking me about this how much worse
is it gonna get before there's some sort
of reset and all of these things and
it's like man I don't want two months
from now or four years from now to look
back at right before the 2018 elections
and go boy weren't those the good old
days because we've gone on the train to
hell so do you think there's actually no
way to stop it at this point do you
think that no I think that so here's
here's the scenarios that I'm looking at
right now if I'm working okay
none of these I know the prediction
business always works out so if you're
wargaming yeah let's look at the next
election what happens well the Democrats
probably gonna win the house okay they
win the house you know they're going to
at least subpoena his tax records he's
not gonna give up tax records
that'll be brought to the Supreme Court
remember that marker number one that's
day number one day number two they don't
have any place they can go on
impeachment they have to impeach him
even if they don't have anything right
they've already said it they have to do
they have to do it it'll be the Senate
that will throw it with L throw to the
Senate that's where the trial happens so
impeachment just means or taking you to
court okay so that's day number two day
number three trump has already filed
with the Supreme Court saying I'm not
I'm not testifying I'm not turning over
my tax records I'm not doing this okay
well Cavanaugh has already said he's
already seen that that's a distraction
the president shouldn't have to so day
number three when Trump has brought it
to the Supreme Court then the house says
wait a minute Cavanaugh should recuse
himself we are looking at a year yeah
where the three branches of government
the administration plus the house and
the Senate both of them will be fighting
with each other they'll be fighting with
this branch and they'll be fighting with
the Supreme Court when Cavanaugh doesn't
recuse himself they will file articles
of impeachment for him and there they're
leading all of these ideas already these
ideas are trickling out if this is gonna
happen yeah so now you have the press
the fourth branch already in chaos has
has absolutely no credibility
at all it's deranged and that pushes
which you would call the fifth branch or
the first branch the people into the
streets how do you solve that alright so
before we get to the streets can I give
you the one option that I think maybe
saves us from all that which is that the
Republicans win or at least hold in the
midterms thus finally as long shot as
this is finally the democrats go okay
we've got to drop identity politics
we've got to get away from this
socialist Democrat Democrat socialist
nonsense there's no evidence that they
would ever look in the mirror if
anything they've only doubled down every
time yeah I see that as the only outlet
to where you're going so I think if you
have if they don't win the house if you
win the house god forbid if they win the
house and the Senate then it's chaos but
if you win the if they win the house the
Democrats that scenario is gonna play
out in some form on the other so that
just gets worse and worse or worse I was
talking to a friend of mine just last
night about this and he said you know
just exactly what you said and I
followed it up with what you said show
me the I know there's no evidence I am
Spartacus is all of a sudden going to
say okay I'm not Spartacus yeah you know
I'm the carpenter from you know from
Nazareth no wasn't that the danger all
along and this this is directly linked
to your book I mean I remember before
the election I kept saying and this is
when I still considered myself on the
left and and someone that had basically
only voted Democrat my entire life I
think the one time I voted Republican
was Bloomberg's third term in New York
City after he had flipped like 87 times
over something I'm not even sure if he
was Republican at that point but that I
kept saying before the election if you
keep calling Trump Hitler then no matter
what he does and no matter what reality
is you'll never be able to get yourself
out of that little thing place you've
painted yourself and that's where we are
so you know what's crazy I lived this I
lived this I said I'm the guy who got in
so much trouble saying I think Barack
Obama may be a racist now I immediately
corrected it in that on the spot
that's not quite right I now understand
I explained it in the book I now
understand how to express that I wasn't
up on anti-colonialism I certainly
wasn't up on post-modernism so I'm
hearing all these terms that mean
nothing to me and yet they're always
attacking groups to me and to a lot of
people in the country that's the
definition of racist yeah okay but I
didn't understand the difference the
other part other part out okay it's now
social justice okay well social justice
seems wrong to me that's how I defined
it then that was so divisive when I said
that and I was really at the time
struggling to figure out what is
happening how who is this guy and I got
more and more strident and didn't make a
lot of friends on the left okay yeah it
didn't work it didn't work my base got
stronger my base learned things but my
base also as things went on got more and
more angry as did I why isn't this
working well because you cannot call
people names and expect them to come
over we have I just saw new poll today
that shows I think it's 8% of the
American public 8,000 people interviewed
eight percent of the American public is
the die-hard progressive radical okay
the the never-give-up
conservative traditional conservative is
about twenty nine percent okay they're
both on the edges 27 29 percent
somewhere in that area still on the
edges
the vast majority is now being called
the exhausted class and it's the class
of people and I'm in this guy's it
doesn't have to be this way I don't I'm
tired of this I don't I not everybody is
a racist not everybody is a homophobe
it's the stop it stop it
the Cavanagh jordan peterson got into
trouble and
I tweeted he did tweeted back to him I
think this might be the first time I
disagree but I put I think because well
for people that didn't see it basically
he said that what would probably be best
and he did this in a tweet which is
never the best way to do it idea and
he's already he's already had his make
up on that and released a corrected not
correction a clarification in a blog
forum but basically he said the best
outcome would be the Kavanagh gets
confirmed but then steps down and what
he meant was that wasn't saying the
Kavanagh did do anything or didn't do
anything but if there's any chance for a
little bit of healing where everyone
gets a little egg on their face but also
it gets a little bit of dignity to walk
away with and the country doesn't come
apart it seems that was what he tried to
do right in a tweet and in his blog post
he's acknowledged that trying to do that
in a tweet probably not the best thing
trying to do that in a tweet where the
people who are reading it are generally
all about politics and tearing each
other apart yeah bad idea that's why I
put I think because knowing Jordan the
little that I do yeah he's a deep
philosophical thinker so my my feeling
was and it turns out it was right that
he's looking at that and saying okay in
in a normal world in a good world where
we're all really trying to do the right
thing and if we really were all trying
to do the right thing I agree with him
it would have been the best thing to
have Jordan say or to have Kavanagh say
thank you thank you now let's bring the
country back together nominate somebody
else and let's go through it but the
other side would have gone through
exactly the same thing you would have
rewarded them in the end they got it
because we're talking about the machines
of destruction so reality doesn't play a
role at some point this 70 percent of
America is going to stand up and say
shut up both of you are you shocked how
many people in that 70 percent are just
afraid to do that because when we do
these meet and greets after the the
Petersons event I think the number one
question I get
asked is what can I do I'm afraid to
speak and I cannot I mean I see this you
know from people that I'm sitting this
close to and I see this look in their
eyes of fear and it's like I don't think
I'm that brave I don't know why I'm
doing this I don't I'm just doing it I
can't explain it I but I don't wake up
every morning and I'm like what am I
gonna do today to fight Google and fight
the political powers and I'm just like
I'm just doing what I think is right
that's it that so that goes - I brought
my family 2011 to Auschwitz and I did it
again because I see over the horizon I
think and we stood outside of the gates
and we had a prayer and then I said okay
we are here because we have to look at
the ugliest thing man has done and we
have to decide who we are who were going
to be because if you weren't prepared
and I don't mean prepare for that kind
of stuff I mean really know who you are
you will not stand when the jackbooted
thugs come down the street you have to
know who you are and what you believe so
I had them read a story of the righteous
of the nation they could pick any one
who saved Jews and to really try to get
into their head I lined up in a just a
family kind of conversation with this
sweet woman she just died I think last
week 90 years old she was a Christian
she was 16 years old when she saved the
first Jew her whole family did it it was
remarkable and we we talked about it two
things I learned on that trip one as we
were leaving I said to her look I have a
responsibility that's different than
most because I speak to so many people
and I said I believe that people have
that tree of righteousness in them I
think they have that goodness they want
to do the right thing how do I water it
she told me something so profound it's
so game-changing
she she looked at me so puzzled and she
said you misunderstand the righteous
didn't suddenly become righteous they
just refused to go over the cliff with
the rest of humanity mm-hmm all you have
to do is remember what you've always
believed was true and they just stand
and just go mmm no you guys are crazy
you don't have to be a hero you're not a
hero she was looking at me she wouldn't
let me film her she only let me take one
picture of her she wanted nothing
because she was like I'm not a hero
I just remembered what was right that's
remarkable do you think that the default
position of humanity is to cower that in
that in these moments it seems like it's
a lot easier to cower right I mean even
now like that's the thing when people
say this to me about we're how do I get
braver or whatever it's like we live in
the freest place in the history of the
world need bravery and if you're if
you're afraid now imagine the second
that thing gets turned a little bit how
afraid you're gonna be so it seems like
like fear and I'm sure there's a
psychological component to this that
fear does something in the brain that
maybe bravery or or maybe it really is
about just knowing what you are and what
you're made let me tell you two stories
first fear shuts your brain down okay it
shuts reason down you're in
fight-or-flight and that's a good thing
because you don't want to be going well
I don't know should I hit him a little
harder swinging so fear and anger really
bad and that's why we're addicted
outrage we will swing you got to get
shake that or your won't think it's
biological two stories the other person
we met with in Poland was the chief
rabbi and he said I think it was 7,000
there were 7,000 people that stood and I
was I mean when have you been Auschwitz
no I haven't when you go there's
churches I mean a block away
there are houses everywhere and they're
old they were there and I left there and
I was enraged I remember crying and and
looking at the houses and screaming in
my head where the hell were you where
were you I meet with him and I said how
out of all the millions of people and he
said you you're thinking that's a small
number you said that's an incredible
number of people people you're in a
scary movie you look away when something
like this is coming it is human nature
to look away or to dismiss and you it's
it's it's a we have this gift of fear
that warns us but we use logic and
sometimes we use it just to protect
ourself because Dave I don't think
people are afraid of standing I think
they're afraid of knowing the truth you
look at the people who stand the people
who stand are the ones who are going you
know I learned something new I learned
something it's changed me they're not
standing you're not standing because
you're brave and I've got to take a
stand you're saying wait a minute I just
scales fell off my eyes I just learned
something when you are inquisitive when
you are based in wait a minute I really
want to know you have already prepared
to yeah but do you really you and I I
know you know this I think we've talked
about it I went through it and you went
through it you do come to a point to
where you're saying if I take another
stata everything in my life could change
my friends might change they might look
at me differently and you take that step
and say yeah I want to know the truth
that's where people fail they if you
can't take that leap and that's why I
I really think you're seeing people like
you you're seeing the inquisitive
because that's in their nature to
question question wait a minute that
doesn't make sense that doesn't make
sense and if you're like that you most
likely have already passed that line of
uncomfortability because you've had
things that you realized you went oh
crap okay well I guess I don't believe
that anymore
yeah and I just don't know how I could
wake up and put stuff in my hair and
look in the mirror and go that's why I
just don't know how I could do it but I
know some people do it and then I get I
think this is what Jordan would describe
is sort of the slow road to hell you
will just diminish yourself and diminish
yourself every every day of your life
until the end just you have to stop
looking you have to turn around because
it will always present you with the
option oh you saw it you looked out and
you saw them just lining up a family of
Jews shooting them okay now what do you
do once you see it it presents you with
the choice do I go back to sleep or do I
stand so I know every you know it's very
easy to always be like okay both sides
are going crazy they're equally horrible
and all of those things like that's sort
of like the easy the easy way of doing
it I'm not saying that's that's what
you're doing here but that's sort of the
easy way to do it and we all fall in
that trap sometimes right because just
for brevity's sake sometimes it's easier
to say that but it seems to me that for
all the people that that absolutely
despise Trump that that hate everything
about the right the right basically has
been in power for the last two years
there's a lot of good things happening
in the country related to economics and
the fact that we're not entering foreign
wars and there's some interesting things
happening with North Korea and a series
of other things and the state has not
used its power to silence anyone what I
fear and this is why I don't think it's
an even Oh both sides or crazy thing is
that the left is about state power and
what I fear is they've said or half of
the country is Nazis we cannot be civil
with them because they're coming to get
us and if these people took power well
now we have everything that you just
laid out because they don't mind using
the apparatus of the state right to
accomplish their goals and I'm not
saying Republicans are always right
about this stuff and they face
screw up all the little government
things that they should care about and
all of that the left has become
everything they said the Tea Party was
okay that we weren't we weren't they
have become violent they have become
unreasonable they want to silence people
and they will silence people that's why
you're seeing people start begin to
stand up and say huh
however it's one of my fears with Donald
Trump and the great thing is he says a
lot and most of it never happens you
know I mean my fear is he has said you
know maybe we should look into the
license of these companies you know I
don't think he means it
but you signal that to people on the
right or the left you're you're
basically saying yeah that's on the
that's on the field of play it's not on
the field of play
although there's an interesting
libertarian argument whether the
government should be giving licensing no
no I don't think they should have
license at all right I don't
I certainly don't want the government to
say you know what you've been a little
harsh so I'm gonna look into your
license no right not at all get them out
of that here's the here's the thing that
people aren't thinking about government
is about to become unless it marries
into it pretty inconsequential because
it will never be able to keep up with
technology so it's got the saving grace
here no not that I was gonna give Google
a lot of the left is concentrating their
power in Silicon Valley and that's where
you can really silence people the guy
who wrote IBM in the Holocaust I can't
remember his name
really brilliant guy well thought out we
were talking and talking about how the
Germans how they silenced people and how
they they cordoned people off and then
just get smaller and smaller groups and
then they eventually put you behind a
wall in a ghetto well they would build
the wall higher and higher so people
couldn't hear or
see isn't that what Google and Facebook
are doing we're building digital ghettos
we have the ability now you can speak
all you want Dave but I'm changing the
algorithm and you're not gonna be heard
I mean you look at what the deal with
Facebook was I promote them I give them
my 10 million listeners and I say hey
you can find me at Facebook let's
communicate then they take those
listeners that said I want to hear from
him yeah and then they changed the
algorithm and I can't communicate to my
own people yeah and we know this is
happening across the board you probably
saw my insane tweet thread about all
that I just started retweeting all of
these people real people not Russian
BOTS right avatars I was taking
purposely real people with real names or
real pictures and they're all saying
they're unsubscribed there were people
who pay it wasn't just the free people
it was the people who pay for YouTube
read or YouTube TV still getting
unsubscribed and it's like what did we
all sign up for here but dare I do it
you you like the biblical analogies I'll
do one here there was David versus
Goliath and I think Dave can take down
Google this Dave I think there's a
chance I mean I think that story I'm
being slightly hyperbolic obviously but
I think that these things have become so
big I mean this I guess is what the
essence of the story was right that this
Goliath this Google has become so big
that it will crumble under its own under
the weight of its own crap basically
that there will be enough people inside
the broken machine that will wake up
that I hope that individuals basically I
hope okay well you got his hope right
yeah and your your three to five years
away from it being a cage I mean their
behavior with China which I outline in
the book is pretty horrific
what giant what the road China is going
down is terrifying mm-hmm and Google is
right there with them and that is evil
that is evil they say don't be evil well
that is the definition of it and if they
just slowly you know
the guy who closes the door on the gas
chamber it was most likely a guy that
was fixing trucks before the war and a
normal guy you don't suddenly become
evil you slowly move into it
especially if you're surrounded by a
group of people that are all absolutely
convinced that they are right and the
other voice is wrong and therefore we
just have to filter them out with AI and
the way they are gobbling it's really
disturbing and the problem is gonna
happen you know we're gonna start
hitting massive job loss probably 20 20
20 21 22 that's when you're gonna really
start to feel the effects of AI when
that happens if you look at history and
we know it all the politicians now are
saying I'm gonna get those jobs back
from China
you know because they're leaving China
because they're getting too expensive in
China yeah so you're not getting those
jobs back and especially because a eye
and robotics are are growing we'll have
30 percent unemployment by 2030 30
percent permanent unemployment so you
look at this what do politicians always
do they got to find a bad guy well right
now it's China but as soon as people
realize that wait a minute it's Silicon
Valley that's taking my jobs the
politician then says it's those people
those people that are building the
robots unless those people also see over
the horizon and become buddy-buddy with
their friends in Washington and they
work together then you have a
surveillance state that I don't think we
ever get out of that's a lot all right
so I think I the first time we sat down
I think I asked you this so this seems
like the right segue for it so for
everything that we've talked about here
and and the addiction to outrage and all
that there's gonna be a certain amount
of people that are watching this and
going wait a minute glenn beck was one
of the people that was peddling this
stuff
mmm-hmm I as well I think I know you
pretty well right now and I feel like
you are honest in your beliefs and
you've you've had some maiya culpas
about some of the things you've said
even just you got into something on
twitter with my friend Majnu Oz and you
fully he sent you a clip of something
that you did about him a couple years
back and you fully you apologized
immediately you said I'd love to talk to
you and learn more and all of those
things I just asked him today what he
said was he coming in yeah and I know I
know you guys in an e-mail right so is
there anything you can add to that about
just sort of how you've changed like do
you remember a moment was there
something about that because maybe there
are people that are going down that road
right now that still want more the
outrage and still or still or you know
as they call it [ __ ] posting on Twitter
and the rest of it if you were trying to
get somebody to turn back no cuz there
were really personal experiences I went
from the you know that that global poll
that comes out around Christmastime you
know most admired men in the world yeah
I was tied with the Pope
just behind Nelson Mandela okay that's
insane that's insane twelve months later
I'm no longer on that list god I'm hated
yeah I was saying the same things on CNN
that I was saying on Fox hey so that was
confusing and it was you know you can't
be hated by half of the country I mean
unless you're just a you know maniacal
you know egomaniac that is just beyond
any kind of redemption you cannot be
hated by half of the country you know a
false hero for the other half of the
country and not go I'm not that I don't
think I'm that so Who am I what part of
it most people will go well they spent
millions of dollars to destroy my
reputation to take things out of context
and they did but I also did things
because my philosophy
at the time was if I can get enough
eyeballs I can get people to watch which
puts me in lederhosen you know singing a
device I can get people to watch yeah
then I present them with facts and my
opinion of where it's going forget about
everything else they'll hang on to the
facts and someone in the press will go I
hate that so I'm gonna prove him wrong
they never did mm-hmm they never would
look at the facts so this is always
where they just want to belittle you and
changes violence and and I and I helped
them
okay I added to that so I'm not saying
it's somebody else I am taking my my
responsibility but the biggest thing is
now on the other side I can look and say
wait all of you in the press you said I
was the worst let me go get the
transcripts see what I just said that's
what you said to the 10th power right
here it's they won't work it's wrong and
it won't work but nobody wants to do
that nobody wants to look they everyone
wants to point to the other person
nobody's willing to go said me but you
think that 70% that you mentioned before
maybe is starting to do that a little
bit I mean again I'm trying if I'm
trying to find how to get out of this
okay and and I think that 70% where I'm
meeting that I know it's a select group
because they're coming they're coming to
see me in Jordan take 70% yeah take 17
yeah
ten committed 10 percent committed
changes the world 17 is your tipping
point so it doesn't take all of us
Revolution was fought by about 20% of
America okay those were the ones who
said I believe in this okay we have to
we have to understand it a lot of the
book is about post-modernism and how
that works and what its goals are what
does postmodern even mean what is what's
the modern world it's not about a
machine
about the scientific process it's about
exploration and empirical data and
testing a and B and living with the
results that's what the modern world is
so when you realize so you would say
postmodern really is anti modern in acid
it's because it's it's going against the
ways that we've been able to measure
anything the way we've been able to you
can only you can when you don't
understand post-modernism and you read
the headline which I did math is racist
you either go these people are out of
their minds and I can't take it anymore
or you can say how how did they get
there when you ask that question you
start to go and peel the layers down and
you see the core of this idea good or
bad that what came out of the modern era
the Enlightenment was this and they say
this is bad they say this is bad that
really is it yeah and anything that
holds this up must be destroyed if
that's math if that's you doesn't matter
if you understand that it's all about
deconstruction and deconstruction is all
about chaos you must not do anything to
hasten the chaos it you have to restrain
yourself the best way to fight this
isn't about Gandhi oh I want to be just
like Jesus no I want to win mm-hmm and
the best way to win is to restrain
yourself from adding any of the chaos be
clear be stuff spoken be the person that
everybody in the room when everybody is
arguing they kind of look around the
room and there's maybe three people over
there that are just laughing and having
fun and just because you will be the one
that will control the room in the end
everybody else will kill themselves but
the the majority of people will go oh I
hate this and they'll make their way
over to you that's what we have to do we
have to stop fighting on the stupid
stuff
the stupid stuff gay wedding cakes good
god man yeah feeling homosexuals right
now today in parts of the country what
do you say we start there what do you
say we talk about something that really
makes a difference really makes a
difference
we'll get to the gay wedding cakes yeah
let's be good people first yeah it's so
interesting how people just don't want
to do the intellectual work and now it's
like we have these we have these phones
we have endless distractions to the
point that perhaps twenty years ago you
might have a moment standing on a corner
waiting for a friend to go to dinner
where you'd have to think but we can
distract ourselves to the point where we
actually never have to think anymore
when was the last time you just stood
somewhere I mean I know you're aware of
all of this stuff but where was let's
have you Glenn Beck just stood somewhere
on the corner waiting for your wife to
meet you and you weren't looking at your
phone or you weren't you know I tried to
do what you did but I can't do it for a
month I'm too many employees that I only
have like five I I try to do it once a
week don't make it every time but just
I'm not going to be online do not pick
up your device go out on a date with
your wife and do not carry a device you
don't have it with you that's important
and it's important Dave because I
learned something with my alcoholism I
was struggling with so many things when
I was younger I thought I didn't want to
think about I didn't want to think about
I didn't want to think about the things
that I had done in my life the things
that I was oh poor me about I just don't
want to think about it and I would turn
on the radio and I turn it up loud and
I'd be driving my car and I never really
consciously connected the two it got to
the point where is so bad that if I
didn't have something to distract I
would literally be by myself and I go
just to block out my thoughts okay
that's a problem and I realized when I
was finally no longer I was sober and
not and not just not drinking was the
time that I was driving someplace and I
must've been driving for about an hour
and I hadn't turned anything on and I
realized at one point I'm just driving
and I kind of come to you know kind of
come to thinking you know about what's
in the car what's happening and I'm like
I wonder what's on the rate oh my gosh
I've been alone with myself and my
thoughts for an hour that's a sign of
mental health yeah we're sick we're sick
so in the in the book in the in the
foreword you very graciously and I'm
humbled that you did it you included me
in a list of names of people that you
that you put in there and you know Ben
had this and I wrote a even wrote to Ben
I wrote is an inscription on this page
yeah like two days later he calls me oh
my gosh we were with each other for two
days yeah and he was like hey thanks
very much and then like at midnight one
night I get this text he's a busy guy I
know to those who are willing to step
out in front of the crowd to question
reason and have dangerous conversations
men with whom I'm a strongly would
disagree with at times but we'll all I
will always consider refound errs of
reason and contemporary heroes Ben
Shapiro Dave Rubin Jordan Peterson brett
weinstein sam harris Jonathan Sacks Penn
Jillette Joe Rogan so I thought I don't
want to make this about me so the one
that I thought was most interesting
there actually was Sam Harris because I
suspect you guys probably if he
disagrees with Jordan Peterson on
everything pretty much everything policy
existentialism meaning a life the whole
damn thing you guys probably disagree on
everything plus one I don't know if we
went no and I thought well this is what
it's all about this is what it's all
about so but would you have ever I mean
20 years ago if you're writing a book
you wouldn't you we still would have
done that when I often joked that my
libraries of libraries
real killer because I was too broke to
actually go get a formal education so I
would go to Barnes & Noble or the
library and I'd go
who hates each other this opinion who
hates this opinion that person and I
would read them both and I would look at
them and say is there anything where
they intersect because that I know is
true if both these people are from
opposite ends of the spectrum and they
both say this is true I know that one
line in both books is true ok so start
small and build the basis of truth and
what motivated me was a line from Thomas
Jefferson that he wrote to his nephew
Peter Carr Peters parents had both died
when his dad was ill he said can you
please educate my son when he comes of
age
so Thomas writes this unbelievable
letter you know in mathematics you have
to do this some literature you have to
do this the last thing is religion I
love it it's changed my life when it
comes to religion above all things fix
reason firmly in her seat and question
with boldness even the very existence of
God for if there be a god he must surely
rather honest questioning / blindfolded
fear we break down on the word honest
honest questioning you and I like each
other and get along because you haven't
asked me a set up question and I've
never asked you a set up question it's
an honest question you hang on just a
second ever cook yeah but but that right
but that that is in as good yeah that
keeps you young that keeps you alive
the minute you stir I knew my father was
gonna die my father was the kind of guy
who always had a book in his back pocket
okay self educated man and he's always
exploring and questioning and he was so
great
NOLA fruitloop be one with the universe
kind of guy huh and I called him up we
were best friends for a long time and
I'd call him sometimes two three times a
day and we just talked about books were
reading and things and did you hear this
opinion what do you think of this we
talked about the future the past all of
it and I said dad I just read this
fantastic book you have to read this I'm
gonna send it to you and he said hmm
that's okay and I said what and he said
I'm tired I'm tired I think I've learned
enough huh three years later he was he
was gone when you when you are not
we're built to explore and when you're
not exploring what's left what would you
be doing if you weren't doing this I
told my wife when she married me this
one reason I've lucked out so much my
wife hates fame she hates wealth
she hates red carpet she hates all of it
because she married me and her family
was like you know I can't marry him he
is a loser he's not going to America
he's not going to amount to anything
when she married me because I'm the
first out of every generation that we
can find going back I'm the first male
that has not become a baker and so I
would probably probably be a chef in
some place or a pool I'm not good at
baking it but I was just gonna say would
you bake me a cake that's the you know
I'm not good at baking I'm good as my
father said baking Sun is about formulas
cooking is yeah winging it yeah and I'm
not good with formulas yeah impatient
you're definitely a wing in it kind of
guy so generally speaking do you feel
it's funny the first half of what we've
done here was sort of fire and brimstone
sort of or laying out you know this is
this thing could really go off the rails
I think the last 20 minutes or so it's
been a little more hopeful
I'm an optimistic catastrophist you do
not want me you do not want to be
anywhere near me on the Titanic until we
get to the iceberg as we're going to the
iceberg I'm saying are you kidding me
have you counted the lifeboat there's
not enough lifeboats we're headed into
cold area if there is if these people
they're gonna be irresponsible they're
not gonna pay attention to the ice but
they're arrogant they're gonna hit the
iceberg and you're all gonna die okay
as soon as we hit that iceberg I'm there
we're gonna make it we're gonna make it
because I believe that when people are
awake they will awaken to who they truly
are and I think Americans are different
we have this spirit in us of exploration
we're the people who cross the oceans
we're the people that cross the Rockies
I have to tell you if I were alive
during the you know the time when we
were exploring I don't even think I
would have made it past the Missouri but
definitely I would have gotten to Denver
in a way okay guys I am NOT going
anywhere I'm crossing okay I always
think every time I'm on the on what is
it the five that goes by the the Getty
Museum with which is that the 405 yeah
yeah every time about the 405 we bumped
to LA yeah I see the Getty Museum up
there and I think if I were a pioneer
and I made it this far I would have
built my house in this valley and people
would have been on the top of the hill
going you should see what's on it I'd be
like I am done but generally people are
explorers and they're good and they're
they're hearty and they want to live I
think they do want to live and they want
to live in peace and harmony I think
that about the Palestinians and the
Israelis when if you could and I've done
it I've done it
when you don't have a camera in
somebody's face and nobody knows you're
talking you sit down in a house of
Palestinian
and most likely average person they're
like I only care I mean I just I want to
raise my family I just want to be left
alone I want to be able to eat I will
maybe a little extra money so a wife and
I can go off for a nice weekend that's
people it's when everybody starts
telling them it's them you know that's
keeping you down that's when there's
trouble you find it weird in a way that
we're thought of as political beasts
because in a certain way we really
haven't talked about politics here and I
find now I'm probably less interested in
politics now today then I've ever been
in my adult life in a bizarre way you
know what I mean like I said I still
love it at some level but like what
we're doing here and what I think the
real conversation happening in the world
right now is is not political there's a
class of people that are trying to make
everything political and keep you
confused and controlled looting the
Russians you see the latest the Russians
believe it or not the Russians one of
their one of their campaigns happened
when I don't remember which was that the
last the last Star Wars movie I think oh
I did see this day they said that the
last Jedi that it was Russian BOTS right
but well that's what Rian Johnson I
guess that it was there is evidence that
they were just they were politicizing
the movie that they were they were
putting out oh you're not gonna like
that robot because that robot it's all
about social justice we're seeing it the
movie did suck and we you know I'm with
you what but what I'm saying is we have
outside influences that are trying to
make everything about politics read the
book defying Hitler the best best
explanation of what happened in Germany
ever written by a guy at the time as a
warning to the West go and you don't
know what you don't know where we've
been you don't know what's happening
here
warning and so he really gives you a
look at what was happening prior to and
you can see it you're like oh my gosh
that's the World Trade Center going down
oh my gosh that's this you
you can see it we're repeating it and he
says right right around 1933 nothing is
not political there is not one topic
that is political when did this happen
to us it's incredible I mean just you
know I never watch cable news anymore
and I don't even watch sports channels
anymore because it's all political but
when I'm not doing cardio I'll just flip
channels and everything you go to his
political the view is now always
political if you're watching women's you
know basically women's television in the
morning the the ESPN now is political
all the time I mean every channel so you
probably turn on the Food Channel and
there's some political situation
happened let me tell you something that
I've never said how loud only person I
think that even knows it in my own
company oh is do my executive producer I
couldn't tell you any of the names of
the people that are running for House
and Senate I'm on talk radio I don't
they don't care I pay somebody to look
at that tell me what's the balance of
the house for the audience
it does not affect me one iota except in
the big picture which movement is moving
I just it it's a waste of our time think
of how many man-hours America has lost
in the last 15 years think of what we
could have done with all of this time
forget about the money is that the best
argument for basically sort of classical
liberalism or libertarianism that if we
could just rein this thing in that not
only could you live however you wanted
to live basically if the government was
just pretend protecting your your life
and your property rights your rights
right that not only would that be good
because you could do what you want but
it would actually save you money and so
but yeah you'd heal yeah you'd still
have it you'd have it still on the the
local side which would be great that all
right you know what I mean is you'd
still have people who tried to take the
local area and they'd be the big boss of
the area so you'd have those things you
know but at least do that
little more control over head you could
control it or you could move to the next
town yeah you know what I mean San
Francisco can be as weird as it wants to
be they could live in you know six feet
of human poop that's fine if that's what
you want to do you know there's an app
for the human poop did you know that I'm
not kidding there's actually an app that
tells you where human poop is on the
streets in San Francisco
literally Glenn Beck it's insane it's
insane
I I remember saying I remember saying
people there's gonna come a time when
you will not recognize your country what
you thought was solid will be liquid
what you thought was real will be false
you're not going to recognize it we're
not only so far past that point now to
where you're like I don't even know who
anyone is I don't know what is real
what's I don't know up and down anymore
we're so far past that what's incredible
and this is a good thing or could be a
good thing because of Technology by 2030
you're not gonna recognize it anything
nothing will be the same nothing will be
the same it will be the difference
between looking at our lives in 2030
looking back and going
tave you remember 2018 when we sat it
will be as different then as if we were
sitting in now and going man can you
imagine what 1920 was like it's going to
be that different you know this reminds
me of a line I interviewed Peter Thiel a
couple weeks ago and he said that crypto
is for libertarians and AI is for
authoritarians
and I think that that sort of gets to
the heart of what you're saying because
maybe what's going to happen here is
that as our institutions our political
institutions academic institutions media
institutions as they become so big they
can't sustain themselves anymore so
maybe we will sort of break off into
smaller communities whatever that means
and we'll sort of about that yeah what
that's what the Declaration of
Independence in the Constitution
encouraged
encouraged break-off do your own thing
you should be a little laboratory be a
little laboratory you come up with
something great I'm sure the other
states and the other cities will adopt
it if if it works we all love it yeah
stop stop
it's it's not one experiment why are we
civilian why are we so afraid of that
because I push that idea constantly and
and it's like you know just that the
laboratory should exist so that if you
want low taxes you go here but then if
that screws over the schools then go
somewhere else or whatever it is that
that play but people are really afraid
of that that somehow we're not actually
America if we don't live under the same
exact laws everywhere at which as you
said is the antithesis of founding
documents I think people just have been
convinced that people are not
trustworthy well people aren't
trustworthy if they never get in trouble
if they never banks are not trustworthy
if they never have to pay for their own
mistakes they're not trustworthy when
you have to pay for your own a mistake
you learn people generally become
trustworthy
you brought a Peter Thiel people ask me
all the time are you concerned about
deep luck
yes I'm concerned about deep platforming
big time and especially Dave with what's
coming with with deep fakes and all
there is trouble on the nihilism Peter
every time somebody says something I
always say you know the guy who can
solve this Peter teal because we need a
platform and I mean left and right a
platform whose Charter is the Bill of
Rights that's it
if you agree with the Bill of Rights
you're not trying to shut anybody up you
believe in these things these human
principles what make us human come on
put your thing on here we're not gonna
kick anybody off we're not gonna do
anything this is a this a place where
speech will be protected because
thoughts are supposed to be dangerous
it's only the dangerous thoughts that
led us to the moon it's only the
dangerous thoughts that invented
television or the internet it's a
dangerous thought that
that said I wonder if I can make fire
like the sky does that's a dangerous
thought you're gonna burn everything
down
well they didn't yeah well I can't say
more than if you saw my chat with Eric
Weinstein a couple weeks ago the
billionaire class is talking now so
there there is some happy to hear that
yeah one other thing on that and then I
will let your staff do other I assume
they have other work to do around here
you people do another work around you
got three oh you got things to do today
do do you think that if we get out of
this thing and it and it's basically
okay out of this sort of morass that
we're in right now and that it's
basically okay that we'll look back on
this and think whoa there was something
really good that came out of it
yeah Barack Obama was my biggest nemesis
you don't know you don't know what it's
like to come under attack until the
President of the United States and I've
had two of them now yeah is coming after
you directly and using the force of his
friends and allies to come after you who
was the other one that went after was a
child it was job yeah during but yeah at
the beginning at the beginning yeah so
I'm calling you after you basically were
like all right well no no no you didn't
get anything nothing
no and I'm fine with that yeah what we
were talking about that will come out on
their side though will look back in this
is Brock Obama and Donald Trump have
been some of the best things that's ever
happened to me and I don't mean
financially or you know whatever I mean
as a man because they've both taken me
by the lapels and shoved me up against
the wall and said what is it you really
believe we are so blessed do you know
that really even my father's generation
he came at the end of you know he was
born in 26 so he you know he saw World
War two and stuff but anybody who really
grew up and lived from 1946 until now we
really have been very blessed but we've
also been cursed
no one has had to have everything about
them challenged I'm a better man you're
a better man because every time somebody
throws you up against the wall we will
be a better country we'll be a stronger
more vibrant more free people if we
behave ourselves and learn from what's
throwing us up against the wall that's
how you end in an interview back good
work
[Music]